we have some major major news today in
our pop culture world that we live in
of course involving Marvel and Star Wars
and what could be a Star Wars Cinematic
Universe in development at Disney how's
it going everybody it's Warren and last
night we got some really really
interesting news about the direction
that Disney is headed
last night The Hollywood Reporter
reported that Kevin Feige the president
of Marvel Studios is going to be
developing the next Star Wars film now
of course he's going to be doing this
with Kathleen Kennedy who is the
president of Lucasfilm and this is
really shocking news but at the same
time it's not it's not a big surprise
that Kevin Feige is a huge Star Wars fan
and it's not a big surprise that Disney
would want him working on a Star Wars
film given his success that he's had
with the MCU and especially Avengers
infinity war and Avengers in game
Avengers in game of course now being the
highest-grossing film of all time
and given the fans lack of approval of
all the recent Star Wars films that
we've got it makes sense to bring Kevin
Feige in to make some new ones but at
the same time it is a surprise given the
amount of work that Kevin Feige has
ahead of him and Marvel Studios phase
four was just revealed and phase 5 is
coming up in a couple of years as well
they have so many new characters and
films are introducing into the MCU and
as well as all the Disney Plus material
that they're going to be introducing as
well so Kevin Feige is a pretty busy man
so it is kind of a shock that he would
jump on the Star Wars train so let's
talk about this report and how it could
affect the MCU and the new Star Wars
universe but real quick I am super
excited to announce that I am officially
sponsored by g fuel if you already drink
g fuel or if you would like to try it
for the first time you can use my code
cosmic to get a 30% discount just go to
g feel calm and use the code cosmic when
you place your order and of course be
sure to subscribe to my channel so you
can enter to win an Xbox one or a ps4
according to The Hollywood Reporter
Kevin Feige met with Kathleen Kennedy
and Alan horn the co-chairman of Disney
Studios late last summer to talk about
the Star Wars universe and when The
Hollywood Reporter recently asked Alan
horn about this collaboration with Kevin
Feige and Kathleen Kennedy he said we
are excited about the projects Kathy
lucasfilm team are working on not only
in terms of star wars but also Indiana
Jones and region and to other parts of
the company including children of blood
and bone with Emma watts and Fox with
the close of the Skywalker saga Cathy is
pursuing a new era and Star Wars
storytelling and knowing what a die-hard
fan Kevin is it made sense for these two
extraordinary producers to work on a
Star Wars film together so Kevin Feige
is going to be taking on the next Star
Wars film with Kathleen Kennedy what
does this mean for the future of the MCU
and Star Wars well it's pretty great
news for Star Wars Kevin Feige is
absolutely fantastic and he's done an
amazing job over at Marvel but as far as
the MCU is concerned there have been
reports stating that Kevin Feige has
told a specific actor or actress that
there is a specific role for them to
play in the new Star Wars film now many
many people have been dropping one name
brie Larson now right now there's no
confirmation whatsoever it's just
speculation about who this actor or
actress could be but there's a lot of
talk going around right now about
Captain Marvel being in trouble and the
MCU she was supposed to lead the New
Avengers with spider-man but now that
feature is a little unknown with the
sony disney deal going on so a lot of
people think that her future in the MCU
is at jeopardy now so could brie Larson
be making her way over to the Star Wars
universe now again this is just
speculation for the moment being despite
the hate that Captain Marvel got Captain
Marvel was a pretty big success it is
now the number one female superhero
movie of all time
earning over a billion dollars worldwide
so Captain Marvel is most likely
sticking around in the MCU
however if spider-man does not end up
being in the MCU and if brie Larson is
going to the Star Wars universe there
may have to be some slight changes to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe in
specific regards to Captain Marvel's
role but again right now this is just
pure speculation
but let me know what you all think about
this I know I did a poll a couple of
weeks ago asking who was Star Wars fans
and who was Marvel fans and over half of
you were Star Wars and Marvel fans but a
lot of you said that you're not Star
Wars fans because of the recent films
but if Kevin Feige is in charge of the
Star Wars films moving forward could
this get you back on board let me know
and let me know
if you would like me to cover some Star
Wars content if Kevin Feige takes over
and also let me know if you think that
this will affect the MCU leave all your
thoughts in the comments down below and
again don't forget to subscribe to my
channel and like this video so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 and if you'd like a
chance to win a Nintendo switch be sure
to follow me on twitter and click the
link in the description down below as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof